one of the most interesting parts of the
bitcoin ecosystem is on-chain metrics it
allows anyone in the world at any time
to look on the blockchain and see
exactly what's happening who is moving
what when and to who that allows anyone
in the world to know exactly what's
going on there's more transparency and
there's more information available in
the bitcoin ecosystem than in the
traditional financial system now why is
that important well right now we know
that bitcoin miners they're actually
moving more and more bitcoin onto
exchanges we don't have to go and talk
to every single miner we don't have to
go and try to figure out what's
happening we can just look right on the
blockchain and see that more and more
bitcoin is moving from miners wallets
into these exchanges now of course that
could mean that they are selling lots of
tokens as bloomberg pointed out here
saying that prices are going lower and
so bitcoin miners are having to sell
tokens now why exactly would they be
selling well if you think about it their
revenue is dominated in bitcoin and if
they want to have any sort of capital to
be able to run their operations they've
got to sell bitcoin to raise that
capital and so naturally as price goes
down bitcoin miners are having to sell
bitcoin get cash and then pay for all
those operating expenses now if we go
and we take a look here we can see
there's a number of quotes that are
important about
195 000 coins were moved to bitcoin
exchanges in may and that's the biggest
monthly increase since january according
to coinmetrics based on the bitcoin
average price around 32 000 in may the
total values of those tokens was 6.3
billion dollars it's a ton of bitcoin
moving from bitcoin miners wallets onto
exchanges if we then look here will
foxley the director of content at
compass mining said i think miners are
just talking about the macro environment
and think it's probably prudent to sell
bitcoin in these levels in order to keep
the operation safe again that's them
trying to make sure they're prepared for
any uncertainty in the future then if we
continue we can see here that the actual
charts there's been two massive spikes
one towards the end of january and one
in the month of may where miners started
to sell lots and lots of bitcoin those
also happened to coordinate exactly with
big drops in bitcoin's price you can see
right here at the end of may and into
the beginning of june there's also
another uptick of more bitcoin moving
from miners wallets to those exchanges
if we then take a look here we can see
that the cathedral ceo said that we have
spent the last several weeks
restructuring our balance sheet and
operations to ensure cathedral is well
positioned to endure a prolonged
economic downturn and so naturally what
we're going to continue to watch is that
bitcoin miners they don't know the
future neither do you or neither do i
but they want to be prepared they want
to make sure they have those strong
balance sheets having bitcoin on the
balance sheet is obviously great in good
times when the value of that bitcoin is
expanding but in bad times when
bitcoin's price is falling the value of
that bitcoin is actually contracting and
so their balance sheets get under more
stress naturally many of the vendors
many of their operating expenses they
only take dollars and so bitcoin miners
are having to sell bitcoin raise dollars
and then use those dollars to pay their
expenses i don't fear any sort of mining
death spiral i don't think that many of
the major miners are gonna have to go
offline but what we are seeing is that
bitcoin at thirty thousand dollars is a
much different environment than bitcoin
near seventy thousand dollars miners are
simply reacting to that and so being
able to see all of this data occur on
chain is incredibly important it allows
us to understand with greater
transparency greater information exactly
what miners are doing i don't know if
you necessarily going to change your
investment strategy based on it but
having more information never hurts